Oh mr. Nye happy Tuesday my name's Billy
I'm a big fan I have a question about
climate change if the photons from the
Sun are are trapped in our atmosphere by
our greenhouse gases then how come those
same greenhouse gases don't block
photons from the Sun from ever entering
our atmosphere is there some sort of
weird cosmic one-way road sign Thank You
Billy Billy Billy you've chanced on like
the most important idea of right now in
climate science when you say photons
from the Sun come in through the
atmosphere that's absolutely true and
they go out to the atmosphere but not
all of them get out at the same energy
now here's here's the strange thing
about light and electromagnetism now
bear in mind we are humans trying to
understand nature and if we can't get
our heads around this it's our problem
but basically if you do experiments on
waves of light or electricity
electromagnetic waves you will find
waves if you do experiments on photons
of light or electromagnetism you will
find particles you can either detect
particles or waves so both of these
ideas have helped us in physics
understand nature so here's what happens
light from the Sun comes in at
wavelengths that our eyes detect very
well it hits the earth and is
reradiating the energies absorbed by the
atoms of soil of bridges of the ocean of
ice and re-radiated or sent back out
again at a longer wavelength so a little
longer and I don't know if you know this
but you probably do the what we you and
I call heat is the same thing as light
at a wavelength longer than we see with
our eyes there are a lot of animals that
see these wavelengths but that's not our
issue you've seen it with night-vision
goggles those cool images
so light from the Sun passes through the
atmosphere hits the earth all these
different materials and is reradiating
at a longer wavelength that carbon
dioxide methane and some other gases
hold in the visible light at the higher
wavelength faster wavelength goes
through the heat at the longer
wavelength does not go through to a
limited extent to a significant extent
and that's why the Earth's warn us how
the earth is warm enough for us to live
and because we put so much extra
greenhouse gas very various species in
the atmosphere the world's getting
warmer faster than it's ever gotten
before it's a great question Billie as
the essence of this passes through a one
wavelength goes back out at a long or
starts to go back out at a longer
wavelength that is held in by the
greenhouse gases this is the fundamental
idea in climate science carry on